hello I'm Neil Gaiman's and I often
think that the greatest of human
inventions is the humble button
thousands of years ago people walked
around with clothes that fell down or
flapped open garments that were entirely
bottomless the inventor of the button
whose name is now alas lost to us
deserves to be acclaimed company phobia
is the word for fear of buttons it's not
a word that gets used a lot because it's
not very common what is there to be
fighting though after all just a small
piece of bone or or plastic with holes
drilled into it to allow a needle and
thread to go through the holes and the
button to be attached to something like
like a coat look buttons people were
scared of buttons must live terrible
lives but he said everywhere after all
why some people even make dolls cute
little dolls that gladden the hearts of
children using buttons for eyes who
could be scared of them no but nine
things they take us back to our
childhoods they make us happy except for
a tiny handful of components and that's
irrational isn't it to be scared
of blackness
you